so speaking of things that
uh didn't follow a perfect theory and
model
uh javascript so there's two things one
had an
impact on the world a huge scale
obviously and it's also still
is one of probably the most popular
programming language in the world
so can we go back to the origin story
uh can you tell the story of how
javascript was created
yeah i was at sultan graphics after
graduate school
for seven years and it got to be big and
successful and divisionalized and
political
and i thought um kind of boring
and a friend who'd been there went to
one of the last of the super companies
the
super startups in in the early 90s there
were several
i suppose general magic was a little
after that around the same time
but micro unity was that company that i
went to and
it was because my friend uh jeff
weinstein had gone there from silicon
graphics he recruited me
and michael unity was doing everything
so
this was like the ultimate sort of
pretend grad school it was doing a new
fab
new semiconductor process it was doing
new
analog and digital circuits on the same
very large but not wafer
scale chip originally it was um
five centimeters on the side it was
really hot too
so i needed a water cooler it was a cray
killer and then they shrunk it and they
tried to do a
home sort of media processor that was
essentially a barrel processor but you
could think of
trying to do all the things that we now
see in modern architectures
uh with short vector instructions and
um sort of wide instructions or multiple
issue
uh and and doing a lot of the stuff in
software because
the second iteration the set-top box was
really for
avoiding the cost to the cable company
of rolling the trucks out
to replace your garbage general atlantic
set-top box with a
slightly newer less less uh garbagey one
so if you could have software upgradable
um
set-top boxes the cable companies uh
thought they could save a lot of money
and add features this is assembly
or whatever it was which level it was
like we were writing in in um
we were using gcc we're writing c plus
plus and c uh
somebody i i worked with there um really
very smart guy
hired from sort of wall street um
hotshot programming consultancy did his
own hardware design as well as software
and
we were working on how to make uh not
only short vector units but general bit
shufflers and permuters so you could do
things like
you know crypto algorithms efficiently
and you could do uh
demodulation of the cable you know
complex
uh quadrature amplitude modulated signal
so you're basically taking uh a to d
converters dumping things in buffers and
then doing the rest in software
all the framing and the reid solomon and
viterbi and all that error correction
so that was really great learning
experience but it was not going to work
it was doing too many risky things at
once right if you
as jim clark said to me when i hopped in
netscape after three years at micro unit
he said oh yeah
you do 10 things each one in 10 odds
it's going to be one in 10 billion
the multiplication principle so you know
netscape was already a rocket and i
passed the chance to go there in 1994
i knew the founders because i worked at
sgi clark's company could you pause for
a second and escape
when was the launch of this rocket what
uh 94
94 was the launch of the escape and i
went there in early 95 in april
okay but oh so you said you missed the
launch well i missed the the end the
first floor employment opportunity
but the ipo was was august 1995. so i
was there for that
how obvious was it the netscape was like
world changing uh what was the
layout was netsk one of the first big
browsers yes so
when i was at micro unity still in 93 we
saw a browser called mosaic
and up until then we'd used email and
we'd used usenet the nntp protocol we'd
use news readers
we used ftp we used all these old
internet protocols
all relying on the dns and tcvip and udp
for that matter um when i was at silicon
graphics we brought up the whole stack
right we had to you know discover how
how to find the ethernet addresses on
your network and then
find ip addresses for them our protocol
all that stuff and it was
great because nobody knew in the 80s
what was going to win all the
proprietary stacks like ibm sna and
decnet
and all these other protocols were
saying it's we're going to do it or it's
going to be heterogeneous future and
instead it was
you know berkeley unix and the tcpip
stack that
dated back to the arpanet that won and i
think we knew it we all knew it
at sgi but the sales people didn't and
so they kept trying to get
multiple network stacks interoperating
but in the end uh it won
and so it that was the internet and it
was email and
texty and it was used very texty and
then uh
tim berners-lee did his thing but i
don't think i was paying attention and i
think the date
when he first did it or when he wrote
the famous email has been pushed back to
89
but i noticed mosaic in 93 because one
of the things that mark andreasen
and eric bina did at ncsa was they
innovated on on the html early html
standard they in particular mark
sent this email saying hey everybody we
think you should be able to put an image
in a page
and you know when he sent that eric bean
had already written the code and
you know i talked to tim berners-lee
more recently just a few years ago and
he was like oh we had another way of
doing it yeah
didn't work out because mark shipped his
in mosaic and this
convinced me of several things one the
internet meant
there was a huge first mover advantage
and being fast
getting on first mattered a lot and so
you know richard gabriel
of scheme and poetry fame has written
about this the famous poetry
what's poetry uh well he's a poet uh
actual poetry he's like he talked about
some kind of song
no no i mean he's the founder of lucid
which is where jamie zawinski worked
before in escape
and lucid was doing you know compilers
and lucid emacs which was a fork of
emacs
famously jamie fighting against richard
stallman stallmax
and so richard gabriel you know very
very brainy computer guy but also a poet
but he wrote a nice essay that gets
abused all the time in fact jamie's put
a kind of warning in front of his
version of it on his site jwc.org called
worse is better and this is about
survival advantage of software in the
network world in my opinion it's about
unix
it started out being framed as unix and
lisp good news bad news because all the
list people
the mit people were like oh you know
this is the crown jewel
right uh scheme this is faberge egg or
common list this giant cathedral of
course we're going to win this is
civilization
and those you know those farmers in new
jersey to borrow from the sopranos those
those kicks down to bell labs they're
just you know there's nothing sound
there it's all hacking
yeah um well guess what won wow so
you're saying this is a fundamental like
principle
of the internet is moving fast wins
you could say in in almost any network
system like in biological evolution you
see
successful alleles sweet populations and
they don't always have
um you know they aren't free of flaws
the heterozygous advantage right you can
get
both parents uh give you the gene
variant and you get sickle cell anemia
right but but if one of them does you're
more resistant to malaria
and so this isn't um a beautiful process
except at large scale and then you
realize that because it moves fast and
can adapt it it can win and
people still struggle with this i i used
to struggle with this because javascript
was done in such a hurry
and the force of web compatibility meant
early mistakes couldn't be
fixed and even the standards process
injected new mistakes as it will
but often standards bodies go back and
making compatible changes you can't do
that with the web it's more like
again like biology you you preserve what
still works you don't want to break
atp metabolism or whatever so um
you have to kind of resign yourself to
the reality of
um worse is better being
enshrined in actual design points you
might not like
and that happened with javascript and
i'm way over it but
it also i think was a huge advantage why
javascript has
kind of swept a lot of programming
domains um
people will say oh it's not because of
merit well you're right but we also
improved it over time in the standards
body i spent
20 years doing that and uh you don't get
that choice it's like
i'm not saying that that was the best
language i'm just saying that was the
right time
to do it and i like to say the
alternative was not to do it i could
have
told netscape i can't do this it's too
rushed and it would have been
visual basic script it would have been
bad
uh so that's a good way to present the
alternative but so you're
it was a netscape and you were you're
written in how many days and why was it
only that many days
and what was the the goal and the
underlying principles in your mind
so the whole i'm sort of describing
worse is better in a frenetic way
because it fit the
the model of netscape when when um
it was known that jim clark and mark
andreas were founding netscape and they
did the first release in 1994
that browser took over from mosaic in
fact that's why mozilla has called that
it's the mosaic killer it's like the
giant monster that kills mosaic
that's awesome and um they knew they
could you know it wasn't that
again it's not like you're doing
advanced scientific research that is
changing the world you're more like
taking down the last iteration the
browser mark did which had images
and you know other importances before
you stopped working on it and you're
making
netscape the new thing that has images
plugins which was the way to do video
back in the day
it had something that's kind of died now
for tiled windows called frames and
frame sets
html tables that was new eric bina did
tables in escape 101
so when i got there they were heading
toward ipo
clark wanted the ipo early i think his
instinct was right and that kicked off
the whole
dot-com era right there was a recession
in the u.s in
91. you can see old law and order reruns
where they talk about the recession how
hard it's hitting new yorkers
and after that uh greenspan really goose
things at the federal reserve and and
technology had been
sort of fermenting in a way that came
together with the internet
and netscape made it you know possible
to do pets.com
to do ebay to get people to recognize a
url on a billboard and then type it in
when they get home
and that was huge um that that was so
fast moving a rocket that uh mark and
um the engineering team there thought we
we need to
make this a programmable browser not
just a a document viewer
not just a video all html with images
and tables and also like you said frames
really plug-ins there's no dynamic
element at all yeah the most dynamism
you get was from a plug-in which
there were a few of them then flash
didn't exist at that point
uh it was i think java applets yet or no
well that's the thing we did the deal
with sun in fact
i was recruited to go do scheme in the
browser remember
guys stealing gerald sussman's beautiful
lisp variant
i was going to do it in the browser
because my friends from sgi i thought
hey we like scheme you like scheme and
i'm like i hardly ever use scheme it's
not really used in industry except in
sort of silos but i like it okay i'll
come do scheme in the browser
i have a slide from my 2017 talk where i
have bruce wallace crawling through the
duct
and die hard he's like come out to the
coast a lot of fun
come on do scheme in the browser um but
when i got there there was no scheme in
the browser because they'd started to
deal with sun microsystems
and my best contact there was bill joy
who i admired as a berkeley unix founder
and
son founder uh and bill got the idea of
making the browser programmable too and
so the
idea main idea was to put the java vm
which at that point was
not really easy to embed into netscape
including the netscape version on
windows that was still most popular
which was the 16-bit
windows 3-1 which was going away
microsoft was coming out with windows 95
and
everyone was afraid they were going to
do you know internet explorer i guess
2 at that point three the next year they
already bought
uh or invested in somehow spy glass this
other
company that shot out from ncsa at the
university of illinois
and in fact microsoft had tried to buy
netscape in late 94 before
i got there and i heard about this later
i heard they offered way too little
money
and so you know jim barksdale and jim
clark said get out of here
pound sand but then they realized oh
this is going to hurt us because now
they're going to copy us
didn't happen right away i'm not sure
when gates internet title wave memo was
written that's the famous memo he wrote
when bill gates realized that microsoft
was going down this
old copy aol path or copy compuserve
path a project called
blackbird presumably after the sr-71 i
don't know
but they were going to make a you know
dial-up service with a custom
content language stack and custom
rendering it wasn't the web
you know they could have content
partners uh they have a lot of money
but it still wasn't to scale the web it
wasn't going to be compelling and gates
realized this and he
turned the company on a dime and they
couldn't buy netscape
again i'm not sure the timing so they
decided to copy it and
once we realized that everybody inside
netscape felt even more urgency and more
of a frenetic mood
and so my chance to do scheme
disappeared when
the java deal started brewing but there
was still a chance to do
a companion language to java because
java was a compiled is a compiled
language
it's evolved and improved quite a lot
since then too but
it was for sort of serious advanced
programmers that cost a certain
salary or hourly rate and people
observed bill joy observed
and i marc andreessen and i observed
that in a mature stack like microsoft
you really benefit from having a
scripting language like visual basic
which became visual basic script in ie3
if it didn't take on
didn't take over kill javascript that
you need two languages one is for the
component writers who are higher priced
and more expert
and the other is for scripters
certified public accountants designers
graphic designers with some programming
inclination
anybody amateurs doesn't matter there's
a much more demonic
uh approach there for programming the
components together gluing them together
some people say duct tape language which
i don't really like
but we saw that bill joy and martin
andrews and i we saw the need for
companion language
and the gleaming r i was to call it
javascript i didn't like it that was
marketing's
plan mark called it moca which i liked
and netscape marketing i think didn't
like that so they said oh there's some
trademark and some software
somewhere that uses mocha so we can't
use that and they tried livescript
in august and that didn't last and then
finally we got the trademark license in
december
1995. but the work i did to prove that
it could be done
was important because i i came in in
april and even then netscape was growing
so fast that they couldn't find
an open hiring requisition in the client
team for me so they hired me into the
server team
and i worked for a month on server team
on what became http 1-1 so i was
actually i had done protocol work at
silicon graphics with greg chesson uh
former bell labs
intern grad student intern who knew all
the unix founders and
greg was very interested in taking um
protocols to the next level with vlsi
because he thought that cpus wouldn't
wouldn't scale up he was
mistaken in that unfortunately moore's
law more than kept up and you have you
know gigabit ethernet running
with conventional processors but i
worked on protocols at
sgi as well as unix kernel hacking and
nfs and things like that so i
i came into netscape to work on the
server side for a month but i was
i was thinking the whole time what
should this language be like should it
be
easy to use might it syntax even be more
like natural language
like hyper talk which is bill atkinson's
language in hypercard if you have ever
used hypercard on an early mac
uh and i thought uh well i'd like to do
that but my management is saying make it
look like java
which looks like c from a distance what
does that mean is it braces we're
talking about visually
yeah i mean like uh what management do
they understand what
they don't marketing didn't know but but
management did like rickshaw
engineering knew and we had a plan even
that was if you have this companion
language you're going to glue things
together between java and javascript so
you're going to have commerce
in memory in the heap with data types so
you're going to want some of the data
types in
java to reflect into javascript you're
going to want the primitive types that
java unfortunately separated from
objects so at least some of them
number double let's call it in
javascript from the c term for double
precision
floating point or strings
or booleans um and
objects and so right away there was this
constraint
looking like java meant kind of the c
curly brace syntax but also some of the
data types and objects like objects and
so on all that kind of stuff
comparison operator garbage collection
even the bitwise operators and the shift
operators including the
unsigned right shift which java had
because it didn't have unsigned integer
types
it said if you want to do unsigned
operations use an operator
and that turned out to be important much
later i'll tell that story five time but
um javascript inherited a
set of uh operators the expression
grammar
the statement grammar up to a point from
java but i wanted a functional language
i wanted
scheme a little bit of scheme even
though it wasn't as clean as scheme
you had to love starting to interrupt
you had a love for scheme and list but
that that that functional language
yes i wanted first class functions
because i saw the need for callbacks in
the browser where
it's a single threaded program all the
early browsers were single threaded and
it's the right model for users most
users weren't ready for mutual exclusion
and
threading so in a single threaded world
you cannot block the user interface so
you have to use a callback and
run later and the without getting too
fancy and trying to capture the
continuation like call cc
does in scheme i thought i'll just make
it easy to have
fun arcs first class functions you pass
you know downward and they can call back
and be called back um and java didn't
have that at the time
it had it took forever to get proper
first class functions
uh lambdas now into into java java seven
or eight i think
it did have concurrency right from the
from the very beginning but you were
thinking that the
javascript in the browser would not have
the luxury of being
concurrent that's right and the reason
was java was going to run in a plug-in
so it could
fork threads and go go to town but the
main action in the browser was in the
single threaded program the single unix
process on
on unix or windows uh and it was where
you had to service the event loop and
then go
you know do things respond to the
network layout some html
render it turn you know widths into
heights by filling containers
boxes the early what became the css box
model
and run scripts to you know make the
thing livelier respond to user input
and all that event driven programming
was
in part like hyper card because hyper
card had this on
event name syntax and so that's why you
have in javascript on click
run together as the name of the event
handler and there's some funny ones on
mouse over and on mouse out
people still complain about those but
you know there are many more events now
over the years standardized but
it was a mix of event-driven
single-threaded programming because it
had to run
in the main thread of the browser where
the action is and
java never got there which meant java
could not interact easily or
quickly or in a nested way with the
document with the objects
reflected from the html document with
the tables and forms and so on
and that that is one of the reasons i
think javascript survived and java kind
of died java was in this plug-in prison
it essentially was confined to a
rectangle
the apple rectangle and while we even
built a next year
nick thompson a friend from sgi who was
an
intern grad student at cmu at the time
built the first version of live connect
to glue
java and javascript together to deliver
on that vision where you do have
commerce between the the data types and
the heap um
did it work it worked but you were java
was in charge
javascript was in charge and java was
just these components these helpers you
might as well do everything in
javascript and what happened over time
it's like an evolutionary filter it just
kind of who needs the plug-in and in
fact
sun mismanaged java as a plug-in they
thought
well netscape is giving us the
distribution vehicle and we don't care
about the browser it's just about
getting java out there and
that was a big miscalculation they then
tried because microsoft's killing
netscape after
years they tried getting into microsoft
and you may remember there was a
microsoft deal
which famously blew up and and
microsoft kicked java out of windows
and that's when they really pulled the
trigger i think they already evaluated
it and liked it on
andershelzbergs.net and you know c sharp
and decided we're going to just not have
java we don't want you know any of that
sun stuff we don't want the patent risk
we don't want
i'm not sure what the fights were about
there was some patent angle to it i
think
and up till then microsoft had been
using
java components like in outlook web
access
which had a lot of javascript to be a
web mail like hotmail like user
interface they had to call the what the
mail server
drew uh http and they they used a
a java object to do this and when they
gave the boot
to sun they suddenly other you know the
left hand gave the boot and the right
hand said we better do something else in
outlook web access what are we going to
do
and they said let's just add an activex
component which is their own
native way of embedding things in
languages and
we'll make it it'll be what became xml
http request which is now a web standard
for calling
asynchronously and it's been replaced by
the fetch api in html5 or html living
document but
this whole lineage goes back to java
being successfully
the loser and getting kicked out and
after microsoft kicked it out
it was a plug-in and you would find it
required for like smart card banking in
in the nordic countries where that was
mandated by law but really didn't get
used much
or you know there were pilots who used
it for um
flight information um but flash
which netscape could have bought but
unfortunately didn't they really
definitely did yeah
we would have screwed it up i mean what
year are we talking about with flash i
think after the ipo so it was probably
late 95 and flash was around was it
adobe no it wasn't no it was
it was called future splash and it was
uh these brothers jonathan
gay i think his name was he he uh came
knocking and
the marketing guy at netscape who was
screening the technology partners or
want to be acquisitions was brutal and
just
everybody wanted to get in on the
netscape you know stock gravy train and
he
sent them packing and they they ended up
selling the macro media and macromedia
was where
flash was created and the good thing
about macromedia was it was a
tool company so it invested in you know
the
best ideas i think which are still
somewhat lost to us of flash
the timeline animation is sort of an
immutable
function over time they had the tooling
around that too like that dreamweaver
there's a flash watch a director there
were a bunch of them yeah
i mean yeah they that was a flash
builder was one of the last ones
these tools were used by real artists
and you know special effects people and
designers
all the restaurant websites around 2005
were done in flash which was
you know we were trying to do html5 at
the same time that was the firefox error
we were trying to make
the web capable enough you didn't need
flash but if you recall you go to a
restaurant it's like
this is kind of like a game or something
it's like a flash all the font looks
small
you didn't like flash from the beginning
you're like this is this doesn't feel
right
not really i actually admire flash's
technology and i'm pretty pragmatic
about these things and i i
realized that you know it doesn't matter
if you're
dealt a bad hand like javascript was a
rush job or if you have flash as a
plugin
and you can invest in the tools and make
it pretty good
you should you should make it better for
your users and grow it as best you can
and what happened with the browser due
to microsoft's monopoly abuse
for which they were convicted and you
know um
even after that until i think firefox
and then chrome
was people kept saying oh the web can't
do x i can't do y
we'll have to have a plug-in we'll have
to have a new approach
we'll clean the slate and have a new web
and everyone who said that
failed and the reason they failed is
because there's too much value
in the web this huge network and the
worst is better principle means that you
can not only start
bad which they all sneer at but get on
first and get wide distribution get sort
of an evolutionary
advantage in the priority of place
but you can also improve it over time
yes and so if you're going to improve
flash and for some reason flash is now
out of favor steve jobs said you can't
have flash on the iphone that was
probably the death knell
put your energy into javascript and that
happened right so we did things
at mozilla with adobe to improve which
bought my macro media
to improve flash and to improve the
version of javascript that was in flash
we tried to standardize that
you